let's jump into this story about the us
army so
oh yeah i know where you're going so i
mean you're you might be uh you may be
an expert on
you know the armed forces you know
having uh actually been
in them but we have a story from uh this
is from lad bible for some reason i
chose lead bible
us army could reverse gender neutral
fitness tests
as research finds women struggle
so i've got i've well i've had family in
uh
i come from i actually come from a
military family everyone but me
basically was either married into or
served and i remember hearing stories
from i i briefly lived just uh
just off of base housing in fort houston
uh fort uh is it fort use this yeah
newport news and i also briefly lived on
fort carson and
colorado i know very well heard a lot of
stories from people who
had no problem bringing up men or women
that women have a different standard
now first of all you know that in the
house of representatives you can't say
men and women they got rid of that
language yeah that's
nancy pelosi's rule she got rid of
gender language what's the situation now
what do you say them you yeah you
how was that woman so but anyway
let's let's we'll stay on the military
thing so i you know i remember hearing
stories from people who went through
basic training and they would say
you know the women would complain and be
given special leeway and things like
this
there were certain medical issues that
women had to be granted
special access to facilities that men
didn't get and so very much were given
special treatment
apparently at some point they wanted to
do gender-neutral
testing and my understanding correct me
if i'm wrong they were saying that
it used to be that women did well in
women's specific testing
and that means they would get promotions
once they went through
once they implemented gender neutral
testing where it was
even for both males and females the
women were struggling to score well
against the men
and not getting the promotions thus
creating inaccuracies
inequity in equal outcome yeah see women
have the equal opportunity to compete in
the same tests yeah
but because the standard was standard
the men just tended to do better on
physical tests meaning the women weren't
in the promotions so now they're
apparently going to reverse this you you
told me that you had stories you knew
people i don't know what your thoughts
on this would be
well let me let me put it in this
context
why do we have men's downhill skiing and
women's downhill skiing
pretty innocuous thing i mean why don't
we just have men and women competing in
downhill skiing
something something for some reason men
can spin faster jump higher
yeah you have man's figure skating and
women's
why do you have men's hockey and women's
hockey men's basketball
men way more bone density oh the shape
oh okay so why is it when it comes to
your national security
that you want to say that there's no
difference i don't get it
okay we are we are very we are in
serious trouble when it comes to this
listen
i i am absolutely all for
trans rights and lgbtq rights and the
respect of the individual and equality
under the law
but we have to let me tell you something
tim in the united states military i
could put a guy
out for being overweight you cannot join
the military if you have flat feet
yep so now all of a sudden we're going
to say and this is what the american
psychiatric
association calls it gender dysphoria a
mental condition
so now we're saying that the united
states military has to accept people
with a mental condition
and then provide them hormonal therapies
at the taxpayer expense
what does that have to do with our
national security that's another one of
these feel good things
while as you just talked about the
chinese communist party
they're building their army they're
growing their hegemonic dominance
they're expanding their navy and we're
over here saying
why can't we be fair and have more
equity and and let everybody play in the
sandbox i have tremendous respect for
everybody who
serves or wants to serve but i think
that someone who's overweight could find
we could find a role for them that's a
net positive for us we don't have to be
in combat they don't have to be
in maybe one of these standard positions
that require the physical fitness but i
certainly think trans people as well as
overweight people could we could we
could absolutely find them to be a
positive for our armed forces
but now you're telling me that the
united states military has to accept
someone with
a condition a mental condition
determined by the american psychiatric
association which means they're going to
have to provide
counseling they're going to have to
provide hormonal therapies and all of
this type of stuff at the taxpayer
expense
i don't think that's what the military
is is in existence for
the united states military is a
volunteer organization
we have to have standards we have to
have rules we have to have
you know guidelines because we
are not looking at being a everybody
come and join and play
that's not what the united states
military is as a voluntary organization
now if it was a draft organization
that'd be something different if it was
an organization where we had obligatory
service
then that's something different but let
me let me just put it in these terms i'm
60 years of age
i'm five foot nine i'm about 206 pounds
this morning i got up and i knocked out
three and a half miles
did my you know push-ups and crunches
and everything
if you put me in a ring
with ronda rousey or any you know mixed
martial arts
yeah you know they probably could get in
that kick on me because you know i'm 60
maybe i'm a little slow
but if i get one punch to their head
what's going to happen you know i defer
to joe rogan on this one
and uh you know he talked about this
quite a bit they got mad at him for it
but he pointed out that
men have bigger hands stronger grit
bigger joints and
it's my bone deficiency density it's all
of those things
it's ejecting power i i twitch muscle
twisting
fiber i think there is an issue if
we are displacing strong able-bodied
individuals with
people who are not fit to serve for a
variety of reasons
but i also think that you know in my
personal opinion
there you know i look at say like a
trans man someone who's born female
is on you know therapy and is now a you
know trans man
i think there's a there's a net positive
to anybody who's willing to serve this
country and we can we can find a way to
make that
work now that that being said i also
understand biological differences
between
male and female and i think there are
reasons why we tend not to have women in
combat roles though i think now we do
this is
right in the in that came because of the
obama administration once again it's
about the social engineering of our
military
let me tell you something uh a bullet
doesn't know male or female there's no
doubt about it
but the one thing that my number one
standing order
when i was a battalion commander and we
ended up going to iraq in 2003. my
number one standing order was keep your
bayonet sharp
and why did i say keep you banned that
sharp because you never know when you're
gonna have to go into close quarter
combat with the enemy that's right
so you know well along those lines
as a leader uh as a commander in the
military now
if a woman were to be in a commander
world do you think you need the biggest
baddest dude like the tough
strong men to be commanders or could you
get small
female commanders that would be as good
or better
than men do you think there's well i
will tell you that
there is an example of leadership that
without a doubt is necessary
if you're going to be a commander of
combat troops
you got to kind of look like a combat
troop and let me put it in this
perspective
if i walked in here with you all today
and
i said and i'm a retired army lieutenant
colonel
and i had no i'm not picking at you but
i had hair like yours in
oh no you see but if i had hair like
yours in
and if i had a little pooch belly and
everything like that when you kind of
look and say scratch your head say man
he don't look like a well
be honest be honest well let me let me
just i'll just make a point now i'll be
honest
without would you say in the back of him
man he you see
definitely retired well you remember you
see what just happened with uh tucker
carlson and that marine
i know exactly what just happened you
got accused of being overweight out of
shape
you know and and again i don't think
that we should have the united states
military senior
officers and senior licidos uh men
attacking
a news personality yeah yeah i agree say
that that
that goes against you know we're
supposed to protect them freedom of
speech
let me say something in regards to like
this this you know army testing and
stuff
i've been skateboarding my whole life
i'm sorry but i
i i actually worked with uh some
individuals who are part of an
organization i'll i'll leave their name
i don't want anyone anyone get dragged
but
uh i had a good friend who was one of
the best female skateboarders in the
world
in a certain time period i went to the x
games vip access
we got to hang out she was a really good
friend of mine growing up and
i got to listen to a top female pro tell
these young women they will never be as
good as the men i actually took issue
with that back then saying like
if you may believe that but don't
discourage people tell them to strive to
be the best
and and to view that as competition to
be better but when you look at
you mentioned skiing i'm thinking
skateboarding there's no question
you watch men's you know x games
skateboarding
and you'll notice a very obvious
difference between the male and the
female skateboarding
but actually uh i actually took some
basic first aid training i've actually
done hostile environment training so i
got a
bit more extensive and when i was
younger and trying to learn some of the
basics of first aid because i'm i'm i'm
get you know i skate it all the time and
my my mom throws like it's important you
should learn some stuff google it and
you know i did
i learned some things about sports women
are more likely to suffer knee and ankle
injuries skateboarding than men yeah but
because of something called the q
angle which is the hip the wide hips of
females
means that their femurs are at a wider
angle than men's
which means they're more prone to joint
injury than a man is and the same thing
in the military when you start talking
about
going for a 12-mile ruck march and
you've got 60 pounds on your back
and really in combat you're carrying a
whole lot more but you
get this you see the sustainment of
those injuries because there is a
physiological difference now coming back
to what your question said ian
i want the best possible person to be
out there as a leader but the thing is
that
you've got to be able to lead and
accomplish the exact same tasks that
you're asking
your troops to be able to do when i was
in combat
i was right up there hooking and jabbing
with my guys if there is a x
percentage of my unit that was dedicated
to a combat operation i was out there
okay and and so that's the thing that
has to happen
you know combat is not about social
engineering
combat is not about equity combat is
about
you against another person and killing
that person
that you know that that's that's what
war is war is hell that's what william
tecumseh sherman said
and as a matter of fact it was a nathan
bedford forest
and hopefully no one gets upset because
i'm quoting a confederate general
but nathan bedford forrest is war is
about
fighting and fighting is about killing
that's the bottom line
is not a computer game where you're
sitting back and you got a bunch of
drones or whatever
the bottom line is someone has to be on
the ground and point
something at somebody else and eliminate
them
and that's what we need to be thinking
about because that's what the national
security united states of america is all
about now i'll say something that will
probably offend a lot of the left
where i'm actually trying to make a
point in favor of women in the military
is that
there's that saying we heard it recently
was that um soldiers march on their
bellies
something that affects that you need to
keep a a military
uh well-regulated in terms of their
equipment not in terms of law
you need to keep them well fed and like
a well-oiled machine
when tucker carlson made these comments
about you know flight suits for pregnant
women
uh i disagree with them i think that you
know uh
a lot of these jobs and i was explaining
is this explaining a lot of people
there's a lot of logistics a lot of
administrative work
look i can't fly a fighter jet and
they're a female fighter pies i can't
fly a helicopter
and there are a lot of female attack
helicopter pilots i was just
a dumbo paratrooper that jumped out
airplanes and i was a an artillery
officer
and what i am saying is that yes there
are positions and duties out there that
people can serve in but there are still
standards that
say your body in your physiology
will only allow you to do x and so if we
want to start having
women as navy seals if we want to have
women's past
just pass the same dog-gone test that
everybody else is
absolutely the and and
don't have what we have seen where all
of a sudden
there's a altering of rules there's a
you know
adding of more chances and opportunities
to get out there and try to accomplish
something
because a lot of the guys don't get that
i want to give you my thoughts on the on
the transgenders
uh uh serving the military issue you
know you mentioned that the
the dsm-5 i think says it's a mental
condition
and that's actually been uh staunchly
advocated for by many trans individuals
because it grants them access to
medication but i digress
i i there's a lot of people who say have
diabetes the
legitimate question is would that would
diabetes prohibit you from enlisting or
serving
absolutely it would epilepsy all these
things
i mean you know heart murmurs
sleep apnea i had one of my captains
in iraq you know what is that just
combat could you
could you run an administrative role
could you yeah drive a vehicle no but
but you may be but again what are you
doing
you're creating two separate classes i
mean but well
you can't be fair though you can't the
navy seals are the best of the best
yeah but you cannot yell but you cannot
create two separate classes
where we say okay you can go be in the
fat boy unit yeah
see no no i'm serious you laugh but but
let me tell you how brutal it is
in the united states military where the
military i grew up in are you the fat
boy
that falls out a run oh man you're going
to hear it
but you become the repti boy soon don't
you you better yeah
if you want to stay in yeah so what
happened with you they'll
i'm sorry they'll throw what happened
with the captain yeah
so if you're if you and listen you're
overweight and
well if you enlist okay you're going to
have to meet height weight standards
before you can ship out the basic
training
interesting and even when you go to
basic training you're still going to be
monitored you still have to make those
height and weight standards
okay and and and again you know on
active duty you got to continue to have
your height and weight test and your
body fat examination if you don't make
it then you go i don't care
what level that you rise to now what
happened to the captain in iraq
i had to send him back home oh geez out
of the comments was it like
and and you you don't know how hurtful
it was
for me as his battalion commander to
look at this kid who had
tears in his eyes begging me not to send
him back
begging me tell him that he he'll make
it through even though he can't get
sleep and everything
but i was he was he overweight no he
wasn't overweight but he
he had sleep apnea and i was seeing how
it was affecting his duties because he
couldn't get sleep
yeah and and i couldn't have him go out
there and the next thing you know
he's a detriment not just to himself but
to someone else
and i had to tell him i got to send you
back home so you need
the best of the best of the best the
cream of the crop top at the top
well i mean you got you got tip of the
spear you got seals delta force or
whatever
and then you got you know your everyday
soldier sailor every marine but
you've got to still have maintain
certain standards through
throughout that strata did the captain
get honorably discharged or did he just
of course he got honorably discharged
but he didn't get moved to a civilian or
like a
non-combat role he was just actually
discharged from the military yeah he
ended up being discharged in military
because it wasn't treatable
but he couldn't be in that machine but
he could be in the combat zone and
and when you talk about what tucker was
was bringing up about
the pregnant soldiers in 1995 and i was
stationed in korea
i was up on dmz and it was called area
one
and in area one before females got you
know shipped up there they had to take a
pregnancy test because why you could not
be sending to area one with pregnancy
tests
because we were the tip of the spear you
you were you were in a deployed
zone now guess what what happened
sometimes you know
little boy soldiers or little girl
soldiers they do little things you know
and the next thing you know you get a a
pregnant female soldier but you know
what the army would not allow us to do
we couldn't reapply that soldier back
even though now that she's pregnant
she's non-deployable she cannot wear
a gas mask because that can affect her
she cannot so she has to stay up in area
one
for x amount of time and then i think in
the fifth or sixth month
then you could you know what would the
chinese do
in that situation chinese i don't think
uh deal with that do they even have
female soldiers
i think they do have female soldiers but
uh i don't think they're in their front
line troops
yeah i think they're they're much more
bigoted i think the left would call them
well as a matter of fact i read an
article recent where the chinese were
talking about they need to have
uh non-feminization training for males
yeah the masculinity training i mean
they are looking at what is happening in
in the west and they're saying we don't
want that
yeah you know what that you know the
advantage they have over us
is actually the biggest detriment that
their people suffer is the
authoritarianism
absolutely it's an advantage for to a
point to a point right
i had a conversation with my an
anarchist friend of mine years ago where
i said
that it is much more efficient in many
ways an authoritarian regime
because they snap their fingers and they
impose their will where we deal with
bureaucracy
granted it's a despicable way to live
full of but you know atrocities and you
and i were talking about this before we
came on air
this is the downfall of an authoritarian
regime
it restrains and restricts creativity
yep and we saw that
you know that was one of the things
about our military as opposed to the
soviet model style
is that our young troops could make a
decision
our young troops were trained when you
think about you know
all of the wars you know it's a sergeant
here's a corporal there that is able to
do something
whereby when you have that authoritative
system and that was the big problem we
had in afghanistan
in training their army was that even if
they were in a firefight with the
taliban
they wouldn't take an action i said what
are you doing well i have to wait for
the call from my
commander to do something i said
something they're shooting at you okay
taking action yeah
and that's that was something that they
had to learn but they grew up under that
soviet mentality so
that's happening now it is happening now
so an authoritarian regime
like what you see taking place here what
is telling you what you can wear what
you can eat what you can think
what you can drive it again
free does not equal freedom thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time